I'll let that one go got a double wall
baby
what do you want to do this let's go
Jack let him go it's just cranky I'll
keep it tight on them
we're here baby couple on him I think
it's close go go no no I want to get
there one first I might him sit out
there all right he's right here how's he
look
stee-rike
in our peeper
oh god ow man I thought that was
definitely a keeper
this fish is less than 73 inches long we
have to release it so he continued to
spawn at least we've got another fish on
the line feels like there's some weight
to this one man but he's right there
that looks like a keeper No
do you think
this was smaller than the last one I
believe
it was awesome for a second
sustainability what can you do
there's something else on you there's
something else on here we have three are
not to first to work of legal size maybe
the tuna gods will hand us one after all
one out of the three has to be a keeper
come on baby one more one more
there they go
I get again
David is another short three short order
the odd company the hook
talk about a Chinese fire drill three
fish on three fish hole understand III
inches getting three shorts right now is
definitely the ultimate ice pick to the
forehead we could have paid a lot of
bills with three keeper fish and me back
on top but we got to keep fishing we
can't let this put us down we know
there's a keeper fish out there oh I
know what upon all right that would have
been so awesome you think that was at
first